[Music]
a new push is underway to tackle one of
the planet's biggest drivers of climate
change
methane is a gas passed or they say
belched by the world's 1.4 billion
cattle cows are responsible for about 40
percent of global methane emissions as
part of our eye on earth series mark
phillips traveled to scotland and met
with the scientists hoping to cut the
cattle methane in half
depending on how you feel about meat
this is either a scene from carnivore
heaven or it's a vision of the road to
hell
cattle grazed on the lush green pastures
of scotland the environmentalists will
tell you that when it comes to global
warming meat and especially beef is
among the worst foods we can eat
that the methane cows belch out while
turning feed into food is a far more
powerful greenhouse gas than even the
carbon dioxide produced by burning
fossil fuels
so the challenge is to satisfy the
world's ever-growing appetite for beef
while also producing less methane
and here at this experimental farm run
by scotland's rural college they think
they found a way because it turns out
one cow is not like another
did it surprise you looked at one cow
and you thought holy holy
cow this cow this stomach content is a
lot different than in this catheter
there's
a huge variation in the stomach
it's all about the stomach well stomachs
cows have four of them we are putting
them reiner roa is a researcher at the
college and has been studying the
digestive process in cows and he's found
that the microbes in their stomach not
only vary from cow to cow they determine
how much methane the cow produces
a brief lesson on bovine biology is
useful here
cows don't actually digest what they eat
the bugs in their gut do
their food mixes with the kind of
microbe soup in the rumen or first
stomach and is then re-chewed before
passing through the rest of the system
and reiner roy's work shows that
genetics can predict which animals will
have the right microbe cocktail to
produce the least methane in other words
you can breed low methane producing
cattle
so you can select you can say you know
that cow that bull yeah they've got good
stomach stuff yes you can put them
together and they can make another cow
with the same stomach stuff yes
how much less we are predicting that we
are uh reducing medium by 50
50
yes so these cows will put on 50
of the amount of methane that they would
have that a normal group of cows would
do it yes
how do they know they measure it
they put cows in her medically sealed
chambers for three days and analyze the
gases they belch out
and there's another benefit
producing methane is actually a waste of
energy for a cow the less they produce
the more efficient they are at turning
cattle feed into human food
win-win
still a 50 reduction in greenhouse gas
production is not the same as 100
reduction which is what we would get if
we just stopped eating this stuff
beef provides about
six percent of our protein two percent
of the global calories people everywhere
worldwide um
if you look at the environmental impacts
beef's about
30 of our greenhouse foods greenhouse
gas emissions so you've got this massive
imbalance between
the kind of environmental impacts of
this product and the nutrition it
provides
a recent study at oxford university has
shown that judged against the nutrition
it provides beef is simply too
environmentally expensive
but let's go back to that bucolic scene
of those cows grazing on those highland
pastures
cattle grazing is arguably the most
efficient food producing use to which
these fields can be put because nothing
much will grow here other than grass and
there are lots of other areas of the
world like that
as with so much of the environmental
argument there's a lot to chew over
for cbs mornings mark phillips scotland
i appreciate the bovine biology lesson
mark phillips but it is a lot it is
something to think about i'm a big
listen i love a good burger i love a
great steak
and i have cut back because of stories
like that i'm not ready to end it
completely but i'm not going vegan
anytime soon no no time soon but cutting
back my lifetime
but i do think this is something
that's a big deal tony it's a big deal
it is i love a mark phillips piece i
also love a uh we found out teddy has a
little bit of low iron content so the
doctor was like make him a burger we
went home we made a burger it was
delicious so i hope they solve it all we
can keep eating them without guilt well
as we do know climate change is real and
we need to
move uh better glad i didn't know vlad
was making okay all right that was corny
we'll be right back
that was bad